I've presented a very basic introduction
to FHIR which is still very much
in development and testing.
The standard encompasses many
other issues including what
values termed value sets
are allowed to define structured
data elements within resources.
I encourage you to explore further and
stay up to date as
the standard develops.
Recently for example, an article
appeared proposing three new FHIR
resources to represent
patients genomic data.
According to Grahame Grieve, a key
challenge facing the FHIR standards
development effort is achieving the
right balance between functionality and
complexity.
FHIR is not intended to
represent all of healthcare.
Rather, it is intended to
contain the key resources and
details needed to represent the most
common elements of healthcare.
I've served on standard
development teams, and
it is entirely predictable that
people whose favorite use case isn't
perfectly covered will push for
inclusion of more and more detail.
Doing so clearly risks
creating the very complexity
that led to the idea of
FHIR in the first place.